so what a big deal we day is right yeah
to be here to be an influence to these
young people how'd you feel being out
there it was so incredible and this is
actually my first time hosting ever and
I think and and for sure we day and it
was such a beautiful experience I had my
little coast to Millie and Ty and
they're just such wonderful young kids
who are doing amazing things and their
own lives and I'm just feeling the the
kids energy on the stage is incredible I
mean 20 thousand kids it's pretty unreal
and I love I love that people are here
to share their stories and ultimately
inspire the kids you know to tell them
that they can they can do anything
honestly so it's yeah it's amazing to be
here it's a great message to say that
you can do anything I like you can like
you're living your dream right now right
are you live in dream you've had a
rollercoaster year and now you're signed
as a solo artist how's it feel I know oh
my gosh that is like it's pretty
indescribable I mean I I've been working
at this since I was young of course you
know being in the group but even before
then I was out in LA trying to make it
since I was a young girl four years of
years so it's it's full circle and it's
such a remarkable feeling and I'm so
thankful to have Charles Chavez on my
side and Nick Ferrer and Atlantic to
it's just pretty surreal and I'm just so
fulfilled and happy and just glowing
really it's so well you can see it you
can tell it's awesome
now you know we're all enjoying look at
us now is that sound well is that sound
indicative like what we expect from your
like first full solo project um well
it's still gonna be pop music but not
really that like EDM kind of electronic
cell but there'll be some personality on
the records for sure kind of similar to
how look at us now was yeah but um
you'll be able to really see a different
side of me but you haven't been able to
see and fifth harmony and I'm so excited
to show that to the world and I'm just
so so fulfilled being in that studio
almost every day
working my butt off and making music
that I love and that speaks to me and
that makes me want to dance and want to
just jump around and also that just
stirs my spirit and then the best way
possible do you feel like for you it's
kind of like a reintroduction like a
coming-out party for you Oh totally yes
to the fullest you know you can only be
so much in a group of course you know
you're half of a whole and now I'm I'm
just a whole person a full being and I'm
able to be represented in the way that I
choose to be represented and I have a
team surrounded I'm surrounded by who
believe in me so much and they know
exactly what I want and they want to
match that and they're just putting all
their energy into it and I have a
beautiful support system it's just
unbelievable so I can't wait for people
to see the room need not to be cheesy
it's true right like you want to get
that out there now I don't you have
nothing but love and respect for those
girls do you think we'll see a
collaboration with any of them in the
future oh that would be really cool who
knows I feel like like the sky's the
limit and there are so many
possibilities out there so we'll see I
mean I know they're gonna be amazing in
their own own way fantastic well
anything is possible and like you've
been saying and you've been trying to
tell these kids like anything that's
possible you know we've been talking to
say a lot about how to affect change
what kind of what that means what kind
of change do you want to see in the
world that these young people can do I
think just being kind to each other we
can start there and I think it's so
important to be able to teach these kids
and tell them that hey we're all equal
and and we're all the same and we all
deserve love and we all want friendships
and we all want to be happy and if we
could just spend time with one another
and build each other up it's so
important to instill that and these kids
especially now because right now their
minds are are developing and and their
their ways are forming so it's so
important to be able to tell them be
kind to one another because it'll go
so far and if this generation is that
then we have such amazing things to look
forward to honestly you know what do you
say to girls and young women that might
have great aspirations for something
like like what you are doing or anything
that they want to give back they want to
go into politics and do whatever but
they feel like they can't or someone's
told them but they can't or there's
something blocking the way well can I
just say to them I would say go for it
and believe in yourself I mean I can I
can kind of relate to that feeling like
blocked and having people tell you no
and having people doubt you and and and
for one second or whatever for a moment
believing that maybe I can do it but
that is such a lie that is so false and
I would just like want to just tell them
and hug them and just say you can do
anything that your mind you set your
mind to don't let anybody tell you
otherwise I want anybody put you down or
put your dreams down or tell you it's
not possible you can do it just block
block the noise out block the negativity
and follow your light and follow your
calling follow what's on your heart I
mean gosh if I would have listened if I
would have not listened to some people
more I feel like that would have like
helped me but I feel like being able to
tell people that don't listen to that is
so important like you you really can do
it and those people who did tell me like
no like girlfriend you you can do and
don't let you know whatever getting your
way or whatever someone said block that
it's so important and I just want to
like tell you guys you can do it if you
could go back in time say like three
years what would you say to yourself
what advice would you give yourself I
would probably tell myself breathe
breathe and that things are going to get
better and just like continue to to hold
on and and don't let go of who you are
because you
this business a lot of people can kind
of come in your ear and you know kind of
tell you some amazing things but can
also tell you some things that are just
negative and you know but I got time for
that okay but I would just tell myself
like hey like don't be afraid just watch
what's gonna watch what's gonna happen
just trust God he has something
incredible for you nice well you got the
light now looks good on you girl yeah
thank you so much for it